mr. technical difficulties mukbang
citation needed joining me in the studio
today reads boxy notes for Joel's spoken
suggesters of salacious superlatives
silliness are we you come nice yes
everybody's favorite Gary Brown Gary
Brannen and now on radio three
flatulence from the Royal Albert Hall
bounces around the internet my grade
hello your chill in front of me I have
an article from Wikipedia and these
folks can't see it every fact they get
right is a point and a ding on the
special prize for particulars which is
and today we are talking about Sidney
Abram well tomorrow if he didn't win a
sporting event or invent some kind of
metalworking process then a bar quite
frankly I'm Anna here either pubs
good thing is if you do the walk off and
then you either have to commit to it we
actually the awkward walk back you just
did
Oh Joyce your awkward walk back a day
it's the teacher walking to the dance
floor at a school disco yes how I like
to call it yeah Sydney a from a welcomer
well he did invent something I want to
give you a point
Anke has invented something it's not a
steel worth and crevasses not even
vaguely engineering but it is
ridiculously much is it an American
person ah yes Wooster Ohio have a point
cap powered glider I'm still gonna come
out as being under engineering I would
like to see you can Howard glider
but this well hell that's a glider
unpowered there's a logical fallacy in
there you can have a power glide yeah
what I mean I love the felt we're all
glossing over the cat park
we're all just googling with powered
glider as the wielder all the power that
a cat is going to supply it is a glider
is my IR danceable power source bestowed
at the bat looking disinterest also
always do love the right way down
Sydney Abram well trap was it something
literary that they come up with
no no I'm 1858 to 1930 he came up with
the well temir method otherwise known as
well tourism oh is it
I was gonna say farming but that sounds
more like religion oh um you're closer
with
legend but not not that post certainly
something cooling a way of timing
downhill skiing the wealth no matter
it's exactly one once are shut door
brick wall oh is it a the bomber that
begins to the nature coming what it's
called is about measuring the hollows
holistic Mahalo Paloma stigmatic I mean
a mystic lettuce and Allah has won it so
logistic um if I don't can I actually
get the word elastic mat soon I'll give
you a point now where it to Amy thought
of it yeah really diluted stuff wholly
speak much no you're only on the up
homie ups not homeopathy in something a
little bit weirder than even that
something that you do as a program or in
a belief sense you believe you're better
so you are better oh I'm gonna give Matt
the point for that it's a way to placebo
its suggestions and hypnosis he called
it magnetic healing oh the poster Marvin
Gaye sexually so he provides classes in
magnetic healing I don't you actually
had anything to do with magnets
I mean well these good having on one
point there guy yeah and I was all to do
with coupons yes ruined magnetic
personality Robin Robin barrack shoulder
apparently Matt Gray's ferric shelter
but this was magnetic in the sense of
charisma and it was clairvoyance and
hypnotic suggestion so someone
schmoozers you better effectively
essentially yeah steric in a car isn't
it it's it is a little bit terrific or
yeah Derek Gordon doesn't heal people
for those of you in the audience but for
those of in the abroad spatsville world
their pakoras their professional title
is bleep the whole thing for Derek
Acorah
is this you'll get my India card yes
that's about right oh he founded the
Institute I was suggested but Ferb you
tix
right I know I know the Institute have
made up things yeah eventually yes what
suggestion says he would suggest you and
what was he trying to cure hysteria
gonna say so no mental health condition
council talking late night broken atolls
quackery a really little bit yeah I'm
tobacco addiction so he was countering
hitting the fur that was a thing back
then that was as I thought to that but
and I thought that was too far ago for
people to even notice
so factory people paying to come to his
office while he sat there in his nicest
suit in his most leather bound of chairs
and just kind of go you know really what
banks do you stop smoking okay you don't
really fancy one now how are you feeling
one like a [ __ ] come back up give me a
tenner next time yeah just as those is
it have you tried you know nothing but
though those those physical elements in
there as well I mean nowadays it
nowadays we've got young little thing
you for but those days asknasa
yeah point block if you try beta don't
that sound like you breathe in fine to
me I have to say yeah a 10-day course
cost a hundred dollars which doesn't
sound like much until you realized this
was 1897 what's that now a simple
calculation is about three thousand
dollars for a course they modern money
and that would tell you to cure your
asthma by thinking about it well nobody
someone to pay me three grand for
telling you you're fine I can do that I
a host Laurel white fibers in
non-sequential numbers um there is also
a large section here on controversy oh
really yes I can't believe that some
preachers and doctors were not convinced
pre-political well some were cool with
it and we're getting a cut as well now
where's this retort have you tried
thinking that you are fine with me doing
yeah uh what did the u.s. Postmaster
General do punched him in the nose
pretended oh go on think it off butter
of that uh as he's dry heaving on the
floor ire he cried as the empty letters
all over it hahahaha good cry lawyer
I'll give you for your birthday
trol I'll give you point for the Hatter
minsum it's the nut hitter II that
wouldn't matter what can the Postmaster
General do them fly what options the
general tab nuclear first or second
class which lagged for sign for nut kick
I'm not signing that well I can deliver
it to next door go ahead we tried to
deliver nut cake today
what would you like this to redeliver
return to sender it's the one of the few
times where the mail service will be
delivering to a package hey you're on
Form today yeah this joke sponsored by
Radio 4 Postmaster General become a liar
yes called a fraud and therefore uh well
he took his inhaler refused to deliver
which the Postmaster General could do
really I'm sorry you're talking animated
yeah the US Supreme Court Benchley
decided in wellness favor and the
postmaster was forced to continue
delivering himself but it went to the US
Supreme Court Royal Mail can't do that
no Royal Mail have to continue
delivering wife the Queen
it is her mail service what what if she
decides in I vivid I don't want him get
letters he has to go into the tempo
isn't that basically what Prince Charles
does these days you're sort up to the
death poem fetch low this orange model
yeah they're giving medals in things god
no well they tries to ignore him
yes well I said going down the depo
she's got a bloody Amazon package again
the entirety of Game of Thrones she's
been on her own one for sixty years
he quickly and nobody laughs at him
hahaha what the thing is they said they
left a card saying nobody was in we have
a mystery hundred members of staff who
was not at the door when they knocked I
don't believe each other the the
delivery person got to the front gate
and this is the guy the hats that's to
decrease on the lamps it could it could
he sign for this please no please Mikey
can you sign just just write down
delivering up the sticks teens hat
just poking out of mug such as hell yeah
Oh what I didn't get the car um Mel was
restored the US Supreme Court decided
his favorite it did make all the way the
Supreme Court um there was also a case
brought before the Supreme Court of
Missouri uh against the Reverend M
Bishop for libel and frankly Reverend
Bishop is a pretty good name you want to
keep him to go keeping up the coracle
scales because if you don't get art
bishop bishop diagonally up why why was
there a libel case against Reverend
Bishop what'd he call
well myrrh Inaba that's no US law that's
opinion and that's right oh really yeah
US libel law hello a Cora
yes no a US libel law is much less
strict than the UK's opinion is just
fighting the First Amendment into my
opinion Derek Acorah is a that's fine
uh actually that genuine exemption on
the UK libel law for vulgar abuse those
are his middle name haha
that it's a snow so anyway what did
Bishop call wailmer a bag opinion
a factual pack a liar y'all give me the
point miserable charlatan Oh Lucy the
charlatan he could take but actually was
a fellow follows one of evil the very
best of party I just don't understand
not having miserable my magnetic
personality tell everyone I throw the
very best of parties they seem to
believe me the Institute they've treated
a huge number of people at its height
how many people a day went through its
doors paying about a hundred eighty
ninety five dollars each it's gonna be a
high number if you check your actions to
guess it yes so people a day how many
people a day went through pack up 100
currency 22 I was gonna ballpark
somewhere around Gary's show yeah 401
400a paying what is now about three
grand E so he it wasn't just him then it
wasn't just him 17 healers hundreds to
Naga refers and typists to process mail
this was a big Institute this is both on
an industrial scale my only is just
raking it in from going hey fine hey
yeah right chaps we need to get in on
this room whoa whoa yeah
engage the time machine will make a mint
there is one practitioner here Jo Crone
genuine old crop yeah no no Bo never
you're not gonna get a more late 19th
century in jail Crone are you really um
how much training did yet before non yes
absolutely right um he wrote his first
hypnosis of a woman patient uh this was
my first attempt to hypnotize a patient
can you imagine busking trying to get
someone to be hypnotized and is
viciously making you a pop at the point
in time so just lie down close your eyes
I'm working for you yes it is isn't it
oh you're feeling sleepy will be like
placebo effect people who want to play
along it may still have worked
particularly she'd been there before a
couple of times
I knew the procedures she might have
walked out of that feeling better
there was one of the one of the people
he hired of course have the vicious
punching method of getting people to be
hypnotized haha oh yeah
well me a summers gun but me I really
there was also booked there was of
course a book what do you reckon it was
it was about I can build you better know
you see it wasn't on the side of this is
how to heal someone a counseling old you
do it as a correspondence course no Matt
I mean your point again how to make
magnetic healing pay not even making it
out that it is actually useful is he he
just about me and my money how I got
your cash our knowledge of magnetic
healing alone will not bring success a
knowledge of the business side is
necessary as well it was a
get-rich-quick scheme I should point out
here you can't libel the dead and he's
definitely dead so I'm gonna describe
that as a get-rich-quick scheme as you
can't libel the dead what again
no pain here well on that opinion
congratulations Matt you win this week
show quite clearly congratulations you
win tiny deep fried mashed potato balls
presented by an American folk hero every
day for a week no no no God they are
Davy Crockett's dainty croquettes daily
ah with that we say thank you to Chris
Joel McCrea Gary Brannen I've been Tom
Scott we'll see you next time
Tom that is my rank in the army
scientific sergeant major sergeant
record yeah you get a point
yeah successfully saying this is
something or someone right yeah we can
go her Sonoma right see everybody that's
US done for the day